今日も ありがとうございました
あの このこの講演でだったと思うんですけれども
ビデオで見たと思うんですけれども
なんか人生の仏教的に調和とか何とか題だったと思うんですけれども
その中で人が人とかですね
企業が作る計画というのは
まあ自業とか自我で作るものであって
成り立つものではないと
そういった意味では 儀式儀礼というのもですね
その計画と同じように見れるんじゃないかっていうような
あの講義があったと思うんですけども
その儀式 儀礼と人が作る計画というのは同じようなものだというような覚えがあるんですけれども
あの微妙に差があるんですよ
企業が作る計画っていうのは自分で作るんですね
この儀式儀礼っていうのはもう初めからあるもんなんですね
初めからあるものに我々は乗るんです
我々は生まれる時は何も知りませんだからね
どんどんこうやるんだよ
こうやるんだよと こうやるものだよと
もう教えてくれるんだから
既成のものなんですね
企業が計画を立てる場合は
既成の計画だけでもだけではうまくいかないんですね
新しい考え方とかあった方がより成功するんですね
だから微妙に違います
自業自得っていうのは
その因果法則と  同じものです
はい 因果法則と言えば
人がいてもいなくても因果法則なんです
だからこれで生命を入れる場合は
生命に関わる因果法則の場合
自業自得と呼ぶんです
太陽も因果法則ですからね
しかし 生命ではありません
はい 他ご質問があったら
はい  あの お祭りの時に巻いてもらったこの紐なんですけど
結構この紐に私執着してまして
大切にしてるんで執着してまして
結構大切にしてるんですけど
この紐は具体的にどんな感じのものだかっていうのをちょっと知りたいんです
どんな  この紐を 聖水ですか？はい
についてちょっと教えてください
それは仏教のお祭りでしょうね
祭りというかね まあ儀式でしょうね
だから まあ仏教から人々のことは大事に守ってあげますよという
仏教からのお守りなんです
だから 他の宗教とは微妙に違いますけどね
まあ守ってあげますよという約束はするんです
と言ったっても やっぱり仏法僧に対する気持ちとかね
で ブッダの仲間に入って
それでも悪いことばっかりやっていると守りはいかないんです
そういうことで とにかく清らかな道に人々は結んでもらうというね
離れないようにするっていう意味がほとんどなんですよ
だから お坊さんたちが一生懸命祝福してお祈りして
いわゆる祝福してあげると
そういう人々はやっぱりそういうことしてはあかんと
まあ仏教を学ばなくちゃあかんと
ここまで心配してくれるんだからという風に
このコネクションが成り立つんですよ
そんなところかなね  それ以上はあまり言いたくはないんですけど
あともう一つだけあるんですけど
慈悲喜捨の捨がやっぱりよくわからないんですよ
うん テーラワーダ仏教の実践という本の後半部分を見ましたら
その説明の具体例もあったのですが
その本の中で者のところは
例えば自分の仲間が犯罪を犯してしまって捕まっているとする場合に
その人に具体的に慈悲喜捨に基づいて行動すると
社会的にかえってまずいことになるから
その場合は捨なんだというような
要約するとそんなことも書いてあったんですけど
これだけかえってわかんなくなったんです
だから自分の友達が犯罪を起こしたらね
あいつは死んだ方がいいやとかね
もう捕まった方がいいやとかね
宿屋になっても嫌と思うと
やっぱり今までの仲間としていたことはどうするのかとね
まあしょうがないと知らんと
もう何あいつ悪いことするんでったと
やっぱりそれは者の気持ちなんですよ
だから犯罪を起こしたんだからうまく逃げろというね
自分がそういう悪い希望もないし
だからクタクタ捕まえられてね
ひどい目にあいなさいという怒り憎しみもないし
まあしゃらないとという
この無関心というかね
なんか頭が悪らしくて
それ先生が言ってた質問
質問じゃなくて説明の中に無執着の気持ちって書いてあったのを覚えてて
ずっとそれだと思ってたんですね
なんかこうつながってこないというか
わかるようなわかんないような
まあ無執着で言ったら
これ生命に対する関係だから
そんなに簡単に無執着という単語は使えませんよ
無執着イコール無関心になる恐れがありますからね
これは関心あるんだけど
無執着という 慈悲喜捨っていうのは
他の生命とのどのように関係なのかということだから
関係という言葉が出てきたら
厳密な無執着は成り立たないんですよ
しかし 執着は悪いんです
執着では悩み羽目にはなります
しゃがる人は悩まないんです
一切生命はみんな平等ですという立場で見るんだからね
だからこの無執着でもありながら
この完全切断ということじゃないんです
関係の持ち方 生命との
はい はい  心の窓を開けなさいということが出まして
弟子 ひどいところを見せようとしない
で 素直に思った通りに答えれば
弟子の知識能力が向上するのですという村長さんというやり取りのコメントであったのですけれども
その時に心の窓を開けなさいということだったのですが
その間に長老の会見で信号なんかで捕まえた時に
止まってる時に寒いですか？とか暑いですか？って聞かれた時に
そう別に暑くないのに
はい そうですってはいって答えたっていう風に聞いたような気がするんですけれども
それは素直に思った通りに答えればいいということにはならないんですけれども
臨機応変に相手との状況に合わせて答えなさいということなんですか
日本人にはついつい勝手に決めつけて言ってくるので
ということで そのままそのまま真面目答えないで
はい そうですっていう風に答えますしなさいということを言っておっしゃったと思いますが
すみません 質問にちょっとわかりにくくて
私は頭がものすごく混乱してしまったんです
すみません なんかそこのよく繋がりがわからなかったんですけれども
そんな調子ではね 心の窓は全然開けてないんだから
どなたか説明してくれますかね
質問の内容は はい どうぞ
長老は冗談で言ったんだから
それはその人の流れについてじゃないんです
ね 何か何かポイントわかります？鈴木さんは質問
わかりません わかりません
心の窓が開けるっていうのは
お釈迦様が弟子と話した時
弟子が心の窓を開ける
それと長老が信号のところで何かですから
全然違うお話ですね  はいはい
古いヴィパッサナーが理解したところは
長老は子供のように遊んでいらして
私たちの心というのは
人間の心は大体閉じていると
日本人はその場合はすごい閉じていると
特に だからその そういうものですよっていうことを自明を面白おかしくおっしゃって
それで例えば信号待ちの時にね
そんな何とかですねって言われても
自然な話しかけないでね
ちょっと変わった人って人もいるからと思って
変だなと思って言ってみた
したら そこでいえ 寒くありませんと
の質問が問題になったら
もう実生活成り立たなくなっちゃうでしょ
長老なんかどっか行かなきゃなんないのに
遅れちゃったりとか 時間的にそうだから
なんか多分そういうことじゃないかなと思います
だからそれほどに閉じているのですから
例えばお教室なんかで
何か人に聞かれた時には
ちょっとその聞いた人の聞いているだけだと閉じているから
その聞かれた方としてはね
その心を和らげるとか
長老と善明さんはとしてあげるっていう配慮が必要なんだということですが
お釈迦様はとてもお上手でいらしたということなのではないでしょうか
そうだと私も思いますけどね
まあ喋っていると  あるお坊さんが阿羅漢ですけど
自分の弟子をいただいてというか
自分の自分がおじいさんなんですね
一応妹の息子なんですね
妹の息子だから出家しなさいと
でも大事に育てるんです
そこでいろいろまあ まあ出家ばっかりしてたばっかりだからね
いろんな悪いことをしたりはする
わがままやらいろいろありまして
ある日 長老がずっとこの人にいろんなアドバイスするんですね
出家たるものはこうであるべき
こうであるべきと こういうことをやってはいけませんとかね
あんた走り回ったりするでしょ
それはダメですよとか
いろんなことを言うんです
その若者は外を見ているんです
外を見ると トカゲがものすごくこのあちこち走ってきて
アリ塚があって アリ塚の穴があったんですね
穴ありますからね アリ塚
大体トカゲはアリ塚の中に住んでるんです
で アリ塚を登って で 待っていて
走っていったのにアリ塚で待っているんです
待っていて 周り見ながらでゆっくり中に入る
でも全然急がないんですね
で 中にちょこちょこちょこちょこちょこちょこ入って
この子はこれずっと見ているんです
それで長老がもう話終わって
君分かったの？私が言ったことが
はい 先生まだ尻尾残ってますよと
だからもう話聞いてないんですよ
こんな話なく 今まで喋ったのに
まああの そんなに難しいポイントは今日一つも言わなかったんです
教える場合はエデュケーションというか
教育ではね そちらに関係ないかもしれませんだけど
教える場合はあらゆる手段を取らなくちゃいけない
その中でお釈迦様に説かれた一つの手段というのは
相手に質問する で これ結構うまくいきますよ
で 特に子供たちに喋る場合は
もう一方的に喋るともう最悪大失敗なんです
それでも子供たちに質問しないと
で 子供たちに質問すると
じゃあ君どう思う？とかね
子供たちは元気になっちゃって
自分やること言うんですよ
それでもう教育なんです
例えば変なことを言ったら
あ そうか じゃあまずいな
それはと言ったら それで終わり
だからもうすごい簡単に
教えられます 人の質問に返事するということで
自分の心の窓を開けます
それそれは師匠が質問をする時ですよ
信号を待っている人が私の師匠じゃないんだからね
あの人は私の心の窓を開けようと思ったんじゃなくて
自分の気持ちに賛同する人を探してるんですよ
だから私は賛同してあげたんです
私には関係ないんでしょうし
あんたバングラデシュ人ですか？というと
はい そうですと言うんです
で 知ってますから この人はバングラデシュのことをどこか新聞記事でも読んだでしょうとね
世間知らずやと ある日
私のアパートの前である日
男小っちゃな小学生 男二人
三人ぐらい あんまりにも大きい声を出してはしゃいでいるんですね
私もちょっと出かけなくちゃ
こいつの姿は大変やばいと思いつつも
さっさと行こうとしたんです
だから 一番元気な子はもうあんた何人ですか？どんな国の人ですかと聞くんと言ったら
あのね 言ったっても君たちはわからないんだよと
子供たちだからね わからないでしょうね
言ったっても そしたら
ではどんな国でしょうか
それで心の窓を開けたんです
それで世界の国々の中からどんな国でしょうかと聞いてやろうではないかと
じゃあわかってるかないか見てみようではないかと
瞬時に子供は心の窓を開けたんです
私はスリランカですと
スリランカ知ってるよ
だからちゃんと私が 私はちゃんと自分が何国の人かと言えたし
子供たちもそれはちゃんと素直に受け入れたし
それだけじゃなくて 次に言ったこと
もっと面白かったんですよ
で 私はもう出て行くんだからよかったね
トラにとってもっと教わらなくてとか言うんです
それもその通りですよ
だってバングラデシュとかそこら辺だったらね
ベンガルトラに襲われる可能性もありましたから
自分の国では虎がいませんだからね
だからしっかり教育を受けてますよ
だから あの 2 3 秒で私はしっかりと対話したんです
それ子供とはできるんですけど
大人とはもう対話が成り立ちません
例えば 3時間喋ってみて
子供は理解するかというと
やっぱり自分の世界でぐるぐるぐるぐるぐるぐる回っているんです
大人っていうのは 自分が言いたいことだけ言えばいいと思っているんです
これがまずいんですよ
人間関係で対話なんですよ
ブッダの教えはすべて対話なんです
一方的に言うんじゃないんです
聖書を言ってるわけじゃなくてね
神の言葉ではないんです
対話なんですね だから
相手の心の窓を教える場合は開ける必要があります
普通だから雑談とかね
世間話とかね 無駄話禁止なの
そういうわけなんですよ
まあ座ってお茶とか言うも
何時間もペラペラペラペラペラペラ喋るでしょうね
あれほど心に悪いことっていうのは
だって誰も喋ってないんだから
対話は瞬間も成り立たない
自分が言いたいことばっかり言って
相手は自分が言いたいことばっかり言って
それでもそれぞれ勝手に自分が言いたいことをずっと言って
向こうも自分が言いたいことをずっと言って
向こうも自分が言いたい
誰も聞いてない 誰の心にも入らない
それでたまたま言葉が耳に入っちゃうと
それはもう脈絡がわからないし
前後関係もわからないし
それで腹が立ったり 気持ち悪くなったりとかね
別なところでその人の悪口言ったりするまでします
だからまあ私はただ まあおっしゃった通りね
ちょっと冗談で まあこういう心の窓は閉めているんだよと
その場合は何を返事したって意味がないということでね
まあそういう例なんかいくらでも言えますよ
じゃあある人が であんた
なんでこの服を着てるの？まあこれは私の制服ですよと
それで何を理解してたかというと
偉そうにもう知ったかぶりをして
自分の仲間と子供たちに説明するんですよ
あの国ではね みんな服はないんだよと
あなた方みたいにあれやこれやとかね
あんたもね あれ着たい
このズボン欲しいとかね
言ったって ほら 見てくださいと
こういう国の人々はね
これ一しか持ってないんだよ
その知識人が何を思ったこと
スリランカ人がみんなまあこの服を着ていると
それでもその人は直せると思いますかね
だから最初からもうまあ話すコミュニケーションが成り立ってないんです
その人はまあ あなたはなんでそんな服を着るのかと口で言いつつも
頭の中でこの変な外人の国の人々がどんな服装をしているのでしょうかということを頭の中で妄想してるのに
それだったらそれも言えと
みんなそういうふうなものを着ているのかどうかね
それで私は結婚はしないとかね
そういう環境はないと言った途端
驚いてそんなことで世界は滅びますよと
あんたが何のことをするのかと驚いた人もいるんですよ
その人は神社の人でしたけどね
皆さんも気をつけてください
日本人とコミュニケーションはしようとしない方がいいんです
話は通じないんです はっきりと瞑想指導すると言えば
では両手を整えてくださいと言うと
こんな感じでいるんです
体を動かさないでくださいと言った途端
もうこうやって振るんです
この時だけ その時だけ
人の話を聞いてもらえば
ということで 私は取った手段も
それはある面では侮辱なんですけど
今こちらにいますけど
この早川さんにね 言うことをわかりませんだからね
この方々は説明してくださいと
というと 私はもっと主語があって
動詞があって ちゃんと明確に喋ってるんです
で 早川さんがそれが曖昧で中途半端で
なんとかもう日本的に何か言ったかという感じもないようなことで言うんですね
だから何言ってるのかと私も思いますけど
ちゃんと通じるんです
だからおかしいんですよ
例えば固定概念  この人は外人だ
だから日本語がわからないんだとかね
ある人がもう英語は全然わからないし
私は英語をしゃべる場合はちょっと厳しいしね
ビシビシしゃべるし もう苦労して苦労して
単語探して なんとかもうしりめすレスで並べたりして
私はもう自分でこういうことを聞きたかった
それぐらい簡単にわかりますから
日本語で返事するんですけど
また苦労してまた言うんですね
一回 この大阪の駅でね
で 大阪はそんなに複雑じゃないと大阪の人々は自慢するんですけど
どこかに行くためにどの電車に乗ればいいかと聞いたら誰もわからないんです
それで駅員に聞くしかない
駅員もわからないんです
すごい時間を取って いろいろスケジュールを見たりして
調べたり調べて教えてくれます
で あるところでなんとか聞いたんですけど
これ時間かかるわ この人
踏ん張ってユーライトアンドユーライトゴーあれこれやとかね
で 私はまた日本語で聞いているんですけどね
それで私はもうもうもうもうもう我慢できない
あのね 私は今日本語で喋ってるんですけど
あなた日本語で答えたらどうでしょうか？と言ったんです
だから人間っていうのは心を閉ざしているということはそんなもんですよ
それはもう私は外人だからこそ
よく派手にわかるんです
皆様の場合は お互いにわかっているんだという固定概念があるんだから
コミュニケーションはしないんです
だから私は勉強しますよ
例えば皆様が喋っていることはほとんど支離滅裂で
主語はないし 動詞確実に動詞がないんですね
私の頭から見ろ 動詞を言わないと何も言ってないんです
すべて動詞で決めますからね
例えばね まあ今日はですね
まあまあ昼なんですけど
あのもうカレーライスなんですが
これ何か言った？何も言ってないんです
だからその場合は相手の閉めてる窓を閉めてるところで好き勝手に回してくださいと
という気持ちでしょ で
私は自分の頭の中で面白くて回しちゃいますよ
この人は昼はカレーに溺れて死にましたとかね
だって何を思ったってもいいんだから
動詞言ってないんだから
だからそれとは私は取る態度はまるっきり聞いてないことにするんです
返事もしない 動詞言ったらすぐ答えるんです
あまりにもひどい あんた何言いたいんですか？とはっきり聞くんです
だから決して自分で妄想して相手はこれ言ってるだろうと思うことは危険なんです
はっきりと言葉にしないと
瞑想の場合でも心の中ではわかりますよ
足音でもわかります 何やってるのかと
だからで 自分勝手に判断しません
相手が口にして言葉にして
どこまで喋るのかと それに合わせて返事を出すんです
心の状況を見て指導したっても聞いてくれませんしね
そういうわけで これは私の専門的な専門病で
皆様にはそんなにコミュニケーションというのは関係ないんだからね
私はやっぱり人に物事を言わなくちゃいけない
言うものは人は知るものじゃないんです
皆様 毎日 23時に考えることを言ってるわけじゃないんです
それで初めて聞くものだから
かなりショックやら攻撃やら分からなくなる
心は混乱する ことをやらいっぱい起こるんです
そこはそう 何もならないように
いかに素直に教えるのかっていうことは
このコミュニケーション世界のこのものすごい能力ないとできるものじゃないんです
皆様方 あまり考えてないんだから良かったんですけど
今日の分析に立っても祈りとは何やと
ではそこで誰かそんな風に分析しているのかと
そんな角度で物のこと見ているのかと
あるいは神を信仰しつつ神を信仰する世界で祈るでしょうね
ワンセットでしょうね
これ成り立たない矛盾だよっていうことは
これヨーロッパ人が言ったらもうもう 21世紀の偉大な哲学者になりますよ
もし私は肌色が白くて
もう国籍はアメリカとかヨーロッパだったらノーベル賞も取るかもしれません
これぐらいのこと だから仏教から言うのはものすごい
もう人間は普段知らないアイデアなんです
だから仏教に限ってものすごいこのコミュニケーションのテクノロジーを持たなくちゃいけないんです
だからそんな気に心配しなくてもいいんです
まあ 私の専門病でコミュニケーションはすごく微妙微観なんです
だから厳しく言うんです
動詞まで言いなさいよと
動詞がなくなると文章になってないんだと
今日かやぬく会館テーラワーダ協会と並べたっても名詞だけ
どんな意味？これ動詞で意味になるんですよ
今日はカヤヌク会館テーラワーダ協会主催の勉強会ありますよと
あれ 勉強会ですぐらいも必要なんです
なんで日本はそんなに動詞はね
無視するのかとわかりません
まあそういうことで まあいろいろ人間っていうのはね
まあ日常会話ではまあそんなにコミュニケーションは成り立たない
しかし 教える場合は 知る人がいて知らない人がいるんです
知る人がデータを知らない人に伝えなくちゃいけないんです
その場合 その人の心の窓を開けてもらわないとデータが入らないんです
で 私はそのノウハウは適宜に使う
何か言いたい時はちゃんと理解できるように言う
まあどうでもいい時はどうでもいいことにする
以上です じゃあ他の質問がありますか？もう時間も時間ですね
これで終了したいと思います
では 向こうの向こうの三宝に帰依致し
我も身 心の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行の功徳
神 先祖 祖国 両親 親族 恩師を敬愛し
一切の人々衆生に回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての人々衆生は幸福に暮らせますように
そして平安でありますように
サンビーディオーイワンジャントーサンベローゴーウィナッサートーマーテーバワットワンタラーヨーサキーディーガーヤコーバワ
ーババトゥサンバマンガランラッカントゥサンバデーヴァターサンバブッダヌバーヴェーナサンバダンマヌバーヴェーナサンバサンガーヌバーヴェーナサダーサッティバ
ワントゥテーアビワダナシーリーサーニッチャンワッダーパチャイノーチャッターローダンマーワッダンティーアーユワノーシュカンバラン
ありがとうございます